[Music]
sorry for a few minutes delay so as you
probably can already figure out this
talk will be about word embeddings for
specific domains so yeah let's dive
right in why do we need word embeddings
for specific domains well there are
really great word embeddings or models
to generate word embeddings but they are
generated on corp that are as large as
possible so they cover every domain
possible you've got two problems and two
main problems and the first is words are
ambiguous meaning that they have
multiple meanings and for a domain in a
specific domain you might only be
interested in one of those senses one of
those meanings of those words so how can
you push those word factors toward
towards that meaning or extract up
meaning and the second major problem is
that you usually have a terminology in
your specific domain meaning that you
have terms that if you use a general
word corpus and look at the most
frequently used words and base your
vocabulary on that you miss those
domain-specific terms and to explain a
bit more about the context of this
question like why why this is important
and also to explain the the short answer
or the problems that I just sketched
let's start by covering the the very
basics of word embeddings so this talk
is meant for people that just started in
natural language processing figured out
that there are a lot of tutorials to get
started with word embeddings but now I
want to use it on their own projects and
specifically on their on their domain so
in order to what we need to cover the
basics are basically the concept of
our words and how can we represent them
for the computer so let's start slowly
first a little bit about myself my name
is Jessica months I'm a master student
at of econometrics at the Erasmus
University Rotterdam about half a year
ago I started exploring the world of
natural language processing and I chose
to write my thesis on intent
classification in dialogue systems so
now I'm also really working with with
natural language processing problems and
a bit before that I got introduced
Python and I notice that bison is a
really cool tool for working with
natural language processing mainly
because it has a great community and
there are great open source resources
that you can use so this slides also a
little bit of a disclaimer the methods
that I proposed here are merely a
suggestion for you to try out by no
means are they the best possible way to
deal with domain-specific problems
mainly because well every domain has its
own cafes so this is just the first
thing and a really easy thing that you
can try out and might actually already
be helpful and then further on in the
presentation I also talked a little bit
about what the limitations of this very
very naive method is and how you can
basically work around those and try
those for your domain so let's start
with the basics so words are basically a
symbolic representation for us humans
with a word we refer to some concept or
something and in order to represent them
for the computer of course we need to
convert them to two numbers as you
probably know you can do that with
Bernard encodings but then you end up
with a huge matrix which is just as
large as your vocabulary that just gets
out of hand real quick so a better
option is to use dense representations
meaning that you take a smaller vector
let's say 50 to about 300 dimensional
vector and
with that factor you try to represent
that word and usually that word is then
represented or the meaning of that word
is represented in that factor space and
why you would want to use dense dense
factors as opposed to two one or ten
coatings is mainly because of the
generalization of your model if you use
a neural network architecture and you're
using one or ten coatings the next
layers after the features will actually
represent dense vectors so you're almost
doing the same thing if you if you're
applying it in a neural network
architecture but the main problem is
that you are training those
representations only on the words that
occur in your training data and with
dense representations you can train
those on unlabeled data so before I was
referring to the training when you
actually are using for example text
classification you have text you have
the labels and your training your model
to make a meaning of that word that's
relevant for your for your application
and the training for dense vectors can
be done on unsupervised and unsupervised
way because you don't need to label text
in order to input it into into the
training algorithm so when will you be
using word representations or dense
representations in your in NLP tasks so
first when you get text as an input
you'll start with tokenizing it meaning
that every word gets represented by a
number and then that number is basically
the input or the sort of maps your to
the words and then after that you
already have the the morphological
analysis and you can already use word
embeddings in your morphological
analysis so if you take if you spit a
word into a prefix and a suffix or take
that out of the
out of the bay the stem of the word and
then you train word representations for
the prefix the stem and the suffix then
you can already use word embeddings in
there so very early on in in any NOP
task you'll you'll deal with with word
embeddings so a little bit of history
about dense word representations it
started earlier than many people think
already in 1986 rumelhart was was
learning word representations using the
backpropagation methods and then in 1992
and and 97 they started working with
with continuous space vectors but only
after 2003 when when Ben geo used neural
architectures for NOP tasks they became
really popular and then especially the
last few years since 2013 and up until
now you got great general trained word
factors on large corpora so who here
knows were to what type of of word
reputation I'm referring to when I'm
talking about the method proposed in
2013 by Michelob you're in the front
post first I think what type was it
words effect false text was in 2016 by
shilling graph and and others and then
in in the middle in in 2014
Pennington and saw her and Manning came
up with with love so these are the the
three previous methods that I before are
mainly yeah different different kinds
not only in in the sense that they well
it's it's a different method so there's
a different idea behind it the very
early ones before we're based on on work
on based methods so what you used is you
would go over the whole corpus you count
all the words and you count all
basically you get all the statistics
from from how words appear in your
corpus and based on that you either
apply Lda or PCA or another method and
from those statistics about word
occurrences and co-occurrences new based
representations and then after that they
started with with direct predictions and
indirect prediction in prediction
methods you also look at at how words go
occur so what are the contexts that
words appear in but you're using more
you're using a predictive method for
example skip tram or continuous bag of
words and these are examples that so for
example where the fact use is a script
Graham and and a continuous bag of word
method fostex also uses that but uses
more neural network architecture and
then there of course with with direct
methods you you it skills bad with your
corpus and if you want to add more at
words or text to your corpus then that's
a bit harder to do but the upside is
that you you can can also capture
representations that go beyond
co-occurrence and and similarity then
the story that was for the direct
predictions the count based methods are
are faster to Train of course because
you only have have to go through the
corpus one one time and because they
they make a more efficient use of the
statistics but then the downside of the
of the count based methods is that
they're their pry that they're they only
take into account the word similarity so
that and not really the the the direct
prediction methods take more the meaning
of the word into account but then you
can also saw what Pennington many Stoker
Manning did was tried to combine the
best of both worlds and create glove
which as which is faster to train it
skills better to huge corpora and it's
also better when you're working with
smaller corpora so that's also why we'll
be using it later on and well these type
of methods are trained on on general
corpora so their alcohol and generally
trained methods and the problem is that
first of all like I mentioned where our
words are ambiguous so they have
multiple meanings but Aurora actually
showed was something pretty neat that if
you have a word which has multiple
senses but you don't distinguish between
the different meanings of the word so
you create for one word has
se3 senses in other words meanings and
you only use one representation then
that one representation is basically a
superposition of all those three in
individual senses so if you would train
the the same algorithm on the same
corpus but then distinguish for that
single word when it's the different when
the different meanings actually when
it's referred to the different meaning
then those three different meanings
would create three different points and
then what you could also do is if you
only have that generally trained word or
a representation of a word you and you
still have that corpus around you could
actually extract the different senses of
the of the words and so only given your
corpus the algorithm that you use and
the the trained word vectors you could
extract multiple the the different
senses that one representation has and
that represented that those different
sensors still need some human
interpretation you will only get
different words that it it's likely to
co-occur with but from humans it's
pretty easy to extract the meaning or
the general sense that is referred to
but the downside is of course that you
need human input so for every time you
do this you need to look at okay which
which word is it
how many senses does it have you need an
intuition for that and then after you
get the output for the model you need to
make the the final call on what the
actual sense is like what is the actual
context based on those words that it
gives us as examples and then the other
problem is domain-specific terminology
this is a problem because if it if this
term falls out of the the basically the
vocabulary that you that you're using
you'll use that
in your model with a random
initialization for for that factor and
surely we can do better than random and
mainly because if you so you could
retrain that model so if you have this
random English initialization for a word
that you want to add to your vocabulary
because it's important to your domain
then you would I don't need a large data
set and with a large data set I'm
referring to a label data set that's
about your your that's a task
classification problem but for that you
need of course lots of text and label
text and that last part is usually bit
of a problem so what you can what you
can do if you have that then you can
train the word factor it's just like
parameter in your model and tweak that
you can either for some methods it's
even better to completely start with
randomly initialized word factors for
example semantic analysis because when
you're talking about meaning of words
your or sentiment analysis story with
sentiment analysis you're referring to
the loading over word and what effect it
has on on the sentiment and not about
usually in word factors you're
representing semantics or the meaning of
the word what you could tie with is or
play with is you could start with with
fixed vectors and then later on in your
your final sets of epochs you could then
choose to only then choose to to update
your word embeddings the upside is of
this is that when you start with your
model and you initialize all the
parameters of your model randomly then
it usually has large update steps
and if you use generally trained we're
done beddings then you only want to
tweak them towards your problem and not
have in backpropagation mess up the this
beautiful representation that's already
there you only want to tweak them in the
right direction and you can do this by
just starting starting with them fixed
and then later on also updating them the
downside is that this is of course
problem specific so you would need to
figure out yourself like when is the the
optimal point in in your your training
where you make the switch them from
being fixed to setting them as soon as a
trainable parameter but of course we use
well we not always have a a large data
set so what if you have a limited number
of observations you might not want to
train the trainer the word embeddings in
your model of course because you're
likely to over fit on that training set
so what you could do is either you fix
them and use generally trained word
embeddings or create your own corpus
based on on a specific domain and then
retrain the word embeddings and then use
that as a as a start so how can you get
a domain-specific corpus well of course
it's best if you would have a if you're
working on on Alexis a text
classification that you already have
unlabeled text data on your specific
domain laying around or related topics
describing
basically on the topic of your of your
problem so for example for intent
classification in in dialogue systems
you might have
a lot of customer interactions and
already recorded those or already have
transcripts from those and then but
haven't labeled them yet
and you can still use that to retrain or
train the corpus and the upside of that
is that it's it's in the same the
writing style is the same as you would
occur in the problem that you're facing
so that definitely has benefits but the
problem is that you usually don't have
this data set laying around or it's not
easily accessible so another way is just
use Wikipedia and it's very easy to just
gather your own domain specific domain
specific corpus and then either train
word and lettings own that corpus or
take pre train word embeddings and then
retraining them using that corpus and
which it could what you could also do is
well Wikipedia as this it's upside that
it has a a lot of a lot of different
domains so basically for almost any
domain you could go to Wikipedia find
articles about it and that would be a
very easy starting point but the problem
is that usually it's it's another upside
is that there are fewer typos and
misspellings in in Wikipedia text but
the downside is is that well it might
not be the same writing style as you
would occur in your problem in the case
of intent specification you could go
towards bloke internet books and try to
scrape those the problem is for every
single domain you would need to find the
right block for you and if those blocks
are if you go from your first block
where you where you scrape this and then
go to your second one you need to go and
have a look again whether
you clean the data properly and most
likely the structure of the blog is
slightly different and you need to take
account for that so then for every
single domain you would need to create a
separate separate scraper so what I did
I would just looked at the Wikipedia
pages and it's really easy to gather
your own together your own on corpus on
from Wikipedia because the new thing is
there already a Wikipedia API which you
can go with Python so you already get
the content from Wikipedia pages in your
environment and then from there you just
start off with initial page titles on
your domain and then from there you you
save the content cut the links go to
those pages and then repeat it all over
again you save the content of those
pages get those links the only thing
that you need to take care of is keep a
list of pages that you've already been
to because you don't want to visit one
page twice because then you're adding
the same text to the corpus which is
already exactly in there and you're not
sure whether this is the right whether
this is a general page which you also
want in your corpus because you don't
want to be only training domain specific
words but also a general in the case of
intent classification chatbots you still
want to have a normal conversation but
you do not want to basically over train
on on those pages and you got the
problem where you'll probably get stuck
in loop if you if you do this for for
multiple loops the upside of this method
over the scraping blocks is that it's
very easy to clean the data
you only need to remove a few special
characters actually one type only and
need to remove the deep page titles our
the the paragraph titles but before you
remove the paragraph titles I was
advised to remove the one of the law
two paragraphs because in those last two
paragraphs are only references and those
references are merely the text of those
references which are not useful for
training because they're not complete
sand sentences and then you can already
tokenize that that corpus and then train
your model so training word embeddings
is fairly easy there are a lot of
tutorials online already so I won't go
into much detail what I used was for
gentium I used words effect and fast
text and for cloth there's really neat
Python wrapper already there on get up
so after you've created those those
domain-specific word embeddings you want
to check for whether whether how they're
performing so this is not fairly
important but would still advise to have
a look at it because it's pretty easy to
set up is the intrinsic evaluation what
you these are usually word relations
that either look at analogies and
similarities between words they are
creative for general purpose word embed
word embeddings but you don't want to
lose that general purpose so the only
thing that you need to keep in mind is
that they're not looking at words which
have a specific meaning in your context
because you retrain them and you want
that that special meaning so you need to
you only need to check whether these are
in these analogies and maybe remove them
or take into account when you've got the
performance that that might be might be
true to that but most importantly it's
the external evaluation where you just
run plug this into your model use them
as fixed vectors well again because I'm
talking about domain where you have
limited label data and then see how they
perform on that
and then go back and change a few things
in in the word embeddings were try
different types of algorithms change
hyper parameters around and check what
what works best for for your domain so
about the domain-specific problem
I was talking about originally I wanted
to do a different data set but the
problem there was that had some
practical issues and some legal issues
so I needed to switch to to this data
set which is from a paper which
evaluates intense classification not
only in 10 specification but part of
their or their papers about the
performance of Intent classification in
a dialog setting and I used this as a
little toy example the downside of this
toy example is that I can't really show
that Wikipedia works well because it's
about Oscar boon - and Oscar bloom - of
course it's way better if you if you try
to scrape the scrape blocks about Ubuntu
because there are more towards the
domain that you're that you're working
in
so because the performances with the
pre-trained generally pre-trained word
embeddings were almost exactly the same
as the as the domain-specific retrained
word embeddings I left those out of the
out of the presentation and then as a
short summary so what I would like you
to take away for this is dense word
representations are very powerful
pre-trained that are very good for
general purposes but you might want to
look into making them domain-specific
look out for the two efforts that I
pointed out so words are ambiguous and
you might only be interested in in one
of the the meanings of that word and the
second one is your the word there may be
words that are very important to your
domain but they're they're not in your
your standard for kibriya vocabulary so
you might want to add them a neat trick
to check whether those to get a
shortlist of those of those words is
just get different
Wikipedia documents because you already
got that imported them and then look at
you have idea of see how they they rank
more in the specific documents that are
on your on your topic and then you can
already get a short list and see maybe
there are some words that you haven't
haven't thought of yet that are still
relevant for your application so where
to go from here after the conference
I'll post by wiki domain scraper on on
github and with it the toy application
so you can also try it yourself and from
as a next step besides the tweaks that I
pointed out earlier it's also good to
look at the the biasness of were
generally trained word embeddings and
they're already methods looking into how
to remove this bias or how to cope with
this bias
there's a cool article about in the MIT
Technology Review and I think it was by
date New York of a year ago where Mike
also addressed the pre justice in in
text data
I'll definitely recommend having a look
at at this video on YouTube and well
with that I'd like to thank you all for
being here also thank the organizers and
if there are any questions please let me
know
[Applause]